tes lèvres personnage de la bande
dessinée française était orphelin depuis
la disparition de l'un de leurs deux
inventeurs goscinny le scénariste qui
avec uderzo le dessinateur avait inventé
ces deux gaulois moyens avant les
français moyens
uderzo vient en effet de reprendre seul
le cours de ses aventures de ces deux
héros auxquels s'ajoutent aujourd'hui le
fils d'astérix c'est le titre du dernier
album
un reportage de gaël monfils tu porteras
mais il est trop petit des pics longue
le pote on peut tu obélix ne soit
pratiquée
il est classé peut pas porter ce message
veut monsieur acheteurs c'est too much
of skulls il faut qu'il commande
tu sais ce qu'ils te dis monsieur
astérix nom qu est ce qu ils ont
vraiment tous les couples ces deux là
cela fait 24 ans 15 longueurs d'albums
ils se disputent pour mieux se
réconcilier ensuite 27 album dans lequel
ils ont tout partagé le repas leur nuit
leur amour indéfectible pour les romains
pas de surprise la recette est bonne on
ne change pas une équipe qui gagne
pourtant depuis quelques jours au
village l'embarras est à son comble
astérix a beau faire l'étonné il ne va
pas nous faire croire qu'il n'est pas au
courant quand on est père par les temps
qui courent on prend la peine de
reconnaître son enfant même sur les pas
sûr qu'il soit de vous c'est tout à fait
dans le vent les nouveaux papas poules
mais il faut assumer
le petit chérubin n'est pas tout à fait
comme les autres c'est fou pour le voit
à quel point il ressemble à son papa bel
exemple à suivre pour les petits et les
grands qui ont suivi le chemin de ces
deux là le grand père du bébé c'est
albert uderzo qui a cosigné 24 albums
avec rené goscinny mort depuis l'e3
dernier il a dû les faire tout seul
depuis que votre vieux complice rené
goscinny est mort n'allons pas eu envie
de créer vous même un autre personnage
j'ai eu un moment 7 vous savez quand est
arrivée ce drame d'abord je me suis dit
qu'un série que c'était et m a
évidemment et puis qu'il fallait il a
manqué je continue ou moi mon métier et
donc fatalement en créant quelque chose
au niveau
et puis bon les faits les choses ont
tourné différemment
madame d'assinie gibert goscinny sa
femme maman encourage à poursuivre
ensuite j'ai eu des lettres de lecteurs
qui m'ont encouragé à poursuivre en me
disant d'ailleurs une chose qui m'a
beaucoup ému en me disant ce personnage
ses personnages ne vous appartiennent
plus avoue auteurs sont des personnages
qui appartiennent aux lecteurs donc non
patronale pouvoir de les faire mourir
il serait aussi dommage de tuer la poule
aux oeufs d'or on nous fait il faut
savoir qu astérix se lit aussi en
japonais dans une traduction d'une
fidélité scrupuleuse que pour lire le
texte en arabe
il suffit d'ouvrir l'album à l'envers il
existe aussi une version 1 10 corse
catalan au total les albums sont
traduits en 29 langues ou dialectes et
vendu dans 120 pays
on atteint le chiffre fabuleux 250
millions d'exemplaires vendus à travers
le monde ce qui dépasse de très loin le
succès de tintin et milou
de plus chaque film a été vu en france
par plus de 3 millions de spectateurs
voilà ils sont invincibles ils sont
riches ils ont tout pour eux mais ils ne
nous invite jamais alors bloqué sous les
étoiles
tirer le lion